il vous a proposé un accord sur ces
réformes et c'est exact nous avons
débattu de la réforme institutionnelle
trois minutes
euh pardon nous reste trois minutes est
ce que c'est exact il vous a formulé un
accord de principe à mettre sur la table
nous nous sommes dit qu'il fallait qu'on
trouve des points de convergence et moi
je suis ouvert
je les dis déjà publiquement et je dois
dire que le dialogue est ouvert avec le
président de la république
point n'est avec le président du sénat
mais moi derrière j'ai les sénateurs et
et sénateurs c'est pas moi qui les
désignent je vous rappelle et il faudra
trouver ses points d'équilibré
il ya des points d'équilibré
institutionnel sur des sujets anciens
déjà conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
senna s'est déjà prononcée ça c'est pas
une ligne rouge
parlons des lignes rouges dans le bas
valais ou cdd des vignes jimmy casper et
reald ligne blanche attire t avec lequel
on peut se retrouver rita sion du nombre
de mandats dans le temps
sinon à sauf si sauf rien généré
c'est dans ces deux choix démocratique
une réduction des nombres des
parlementaires dans les territoires mais
ça n'est pas ce n'est pas ce en sus
critot quelque chose qui relève de la
constitution ce qui relève de la
constitution c'est le rôle du sénat dans
la représentation des territoires et
notamment pour sortir de l'étau du seul
critère démographique et je le dis parce
que je suis l'élu d'un département
richer démographie il est important que
le sénat parce que avoir deux chambres
c'est par avoir des champs qui
automatiquement se ressemblent ii y
compris dans la nature de la
représentation assemblée nationale
représente en direct les citoyens et le
peuple nous représentons les territoires
et les citoyens au travers du suffrage
universel indirect
voilà des points sur lequel nous pouvons
nous retrouver
ce que j'ai retenu de notre échange avec
le président de la république que
c'était l'année de change positif qui
nous permettait d'avancer dira donc un
nouvelle rencontre que sur mentionnant
un fonctionnement des institutions
je suis pas camper dans un coin et je
considère que le président non plus il
est légitime a fait qu'il n'est pas
légitime qui s'inquiètent non il est
légitime donc il est légitime que sa
légitimité est la mienne eh bien nous
dialoguions c'est ma conception de la
démocratie bono dit ce soir que sur les
grandes réformes constitutionnelle
envisagée par le chef de l'état nous
allons poursuivre le dise que vous
pouvez comprendre le chef de l'état et
lui a commencé à vous comprendre je
crois a donc le final est le croit
benefit et pouvons nous comprendre
sur un certain nombre de points j'espère
que nous irons au bout
en tous les cas ça n'est pas une espèce
de coup de part et d'autre ça que je
veux vous dire d'accord je peux
comprendre et je pense que certaines
évolutions savez j'ai souvent dire
attention touche pas la constitution
tous les matins oui si on le fait on le
mesure bien ça n'est pas un coup toucher
à la constitution
ça doit être strictement nécessaires et
permettre à notre pays de mieux
fonctionner à notre démocratie d'être
renforcée et aux citoyens d'avoir
confiance dans la décision politique qui
est prise on en gagnera